The Joe Rogan experience.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're a guy who trains as much as you,
I mean every chance your body gets to actually rest,
your body's probably like right about now.
It's a good time.
It doesn't take much.
We're getting a car for we out to dry where she's driving.
Where am I going?
Oh,
we didn't want to travel yet.
My bad bay.
Well a guy who works as hard as you do because one of the things that you are
known for man is your cardio.
You have crazy fucking cardio and you notice it in fights where around the
second and the third round I started seeing your opponents start to slow down a
little bit and then you ramp up like a Lila Tfa.
A perfect example.
That was a great fight for you because that guy is a tank is a tank.
Very scary dude hits really fucking hard,
strong as shit.
But he's a,
he's a god that relies on that explosive power.
He's like a sprinter and a lot of ways and you can only do that for so long and
you could say like somewhere around the second round it was real obvious that
you weren't slowing down at all and he was taking some big deep breaths and it's
just,
it's harder for him if you always had that kind of cardio.
I mean I got it in wrestling,
I guess I was big,
you know,
and I was,
especially when I got to 300 pounds and I was still working cardio,
trying to get down as a heavyweight to wrestle and B,
I always studied little guy's film,
you know like the Henry Cejudo filmed and shit like that when I was in college.
That's just what I watched my cousin like wash heavy ways.
Nobody,
Nah,
I want to move.
I won't footwork,
I want to fake,
I want to take shots,
like I lead my team and take downs as a heavyweight because I've moved around.
It's a big guy and the same thing I've had met the one match,
the guy was beating me.
What?
15 to one if you need one more point.
The technical ones,
the third point in third round,
but he gas and I was still going.
I came back and beat them in overtime because,
because I can just keep going.
I was the mindset God is going to break eventually.
Yeah.
My coach always said Eq fresh.
Even if you're tired as dog shit,
stand up and act fresh like no matter what,
look fresh and you'll be surprised how your mind take over and you realized
later on you're not really tired and when you're tired keep pushing because the
next time you usually get tired around at three minute mark and make it to about
the seven,
eight minutes.
That's like 15 you start doing those grind matches and you go 30 minutes lie and
when it's done I'm able to walk,
say code your hand and go grab another partner or we'll get on a treadmill.
There's,
because we always push as a big guy.
So you've got,
imagine when I came down to two oh five it was like,
yeah,
it was crazy.
Like this is it.
This is like magic.
I can do this all day.
Coach fire rounds.
At first.
Jim,
my five round fight with Jimmy when they called me off the main event.
Now you've got to train six rounds like okay,
like was moon occasion.
We did three rounds mark like you know you're doing six a day.
That's fine.
Gave me three new partners went and they was tired and I'll still go like,
dude,
your cardio is crazy.
It's just a mental.
Even when I'm tired I'll never show it.
He's like I just got to act fresh and get through it.
It can only last so long.
My father told me that forever.
It is a weird thing isn't it?
That your,
your mind can give you more energy.
Like you know that feeling that sometimes you're on a treadmill or something
like that and you're running and a great song comes on and all of a sudden
you're like woo.
You like feel it.
Like you've got all sudden extra like where's I retired from?
It's coming from your mind,
your mind at one beat,
the UPTEMPO beat and start pumping.
Are you going to start dancing while you're running in like three to five
minutes?
I have a loan that some cause you like on a sprint.
Yeah.
They want that song in your head.
Then you really feel the tone changed your God.
Shit,
I'm tired of.
It's crazy isn't it?
That that's some,
there's a switch in your mind that you almost like you have to figure out where
it is.
You got to go find it in a song can find it for you.
But like for you just to be able to pull it out like especially in a fight or
something like that.
When you're battling doubt in this and that and you know,
you're wondering how he's doing.
You know,
is he okay?
Is he tired?
Am I on who's tired or me or him.
You know,
there's that switch in your mind that if you could just access that all the time
and keep it on.
One of the things,
I think one of the guys I looked up to when I was in college,
you know who has passed Steve Prefontaine.
I said,
watch this story at a time.
His quotes to do anything,
anything less than your best is a waste of a gift.
You know,
like everything he ran,
he didn't his cross country Bogash Trot and a pacing and day.
He said,
I'm running to like I'm sprinting.
You're like,
I watched all his movies,
the movies on him,
how his mindset,
even at one race when he was full of spray and they say it's hard,
it's gonna give.
He gave out right before the finish line.
Like I'd rather go out that way,
then pacing my whole the whole time and then try to sprint in and failed because
I wasn't ready.
So that's like in my fight,
I start off so fast,
that's just,
I'm going all out.
You're not,
there's no fill out period.
We're going to touch gloves and I'm ready to move.
And I already know,
like if I'm getting tired,
I know this guy's getting tired.
Right?
He's not trained like I'm training and if he is trying to like I'm training,
he might not be tired by Mama.
I'm thinking he's getting tired,
so I just keep pushing because eventually he's going to break.
He's going to break before me.